[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les républicains sont aujourd'hui aussi
et toujours cette force qui peut porter
et incarner le rassemblement puisque
qu'on voit autant de monde ici c'est que
on est victime de notre succès ya place
assise et un bon panel de candidats
représentent tous les idées de la droite
l'europe c'est une espérance et le débat
en grande partie d'une volonté française
pour l'heure france transformant
l'europe
soyons tous ensemble à ce rendez vous
électoral qui était en rendez vous pour
l'histoire des jeunes qui en vol donc on
peut espérer
bon résultat face à la crise migratoire
qui est devant nous et non pas derrière
nous nous avons besoin de faire des
choix courageux en europe face à la
crise économique
nous avons besoin de sortir de cette
naïveté coupable naïveté de la france en
europe
naïveté de l'europe dans le monde nous
avons besoin de défendre de nouveau nos
entreprises nos emplois de défendre nos
agriculteurs il faut savoir protéger
notre civilisation
il faut savoir re dire qui nous sommes
nous ne voulons pas subir notre avenir
parce que nous sommes européens nous
voulons écrire notre histoire et nous
avons besoin de changer l'europe pour
pouvoir écrire notre histoire
et maintenant nous devons adapter pour
que l'europe existe pour que l'europe
garde sa place au sein du monde ça c'est
maintenant la nouvelle génération qui
doit le mettre en place
prometteur est on en train de se
reconstruire on gère le rond avec toi
avec toute cette liste dynamique et
sympathique
nous devons ensemble entamé la marche
vers les futures victoires car ces
victoires c'est ensemble que nous les
construire on voulait construire ont
pour nos concitoyens nous les construire
ont pour notre parti et surtout nous les
construire ont pour l'europe et pour la
france
le chemin ce n'est pas le mirage des
manuels macron qui ne repose sur rien et
non ça n'est pas non plus l'immense
effondrement que représenterait pour la
france la séparation de la construction
européenne
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réaffirmer le sens de la frontière
arrêter de subir ne plus se soumettre
retrouvé le goût de l'ambition et de la
conquête redessiné l'avenir de cette
civilisation européenne que nous
chérissons se réapproprier ce que nous
sommes
pour mieux assurer ce que nous serons
c'est cela la vraie question qui nous
attend pas pour ou contre l'europe mais
l'europe que nous voulons
il est temps de rendre aux français
l'europe qu'ils veulent
[Musique]
et
carson
mail
ok
[Musique]
et
waouh
en
comment
à
[Musique]
art
[Applaudissements]